welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and i'm a simple man with simple needs i
see a spider-man 3 image
i make a bloody video now i do have a
certain set of skills
skills that make me a nightmare for
people like kevin feige
and throughout this video we're going to
be breaking down all the ins and outs of
the new leaked spider-man 3 set images
and giving our theories on them is that
is that harry us
we'll get into it now if you enjoy the
breakdown i'd love it if you showed some
spider sense
and click the thumbs up button and make
sure you smash subscribe to stick around
for the worst breakdowns on the web
i mean i mean best i meant best now now
as a thank you we're giving away three
copies of the lord of the rings in
hobbit 4k box sets to our subscribers
but i'll tell you more about how to
enter that at the end of the video
now the photographs of the set were
taken by just jared
and they show a lot of the ins and outs
of not only the time setting
but also the suit and peter parker in
full detail
though the webhead's costume is still
carrying across the black and red color
design from last time
there's actually a minute change that
brings it slightly more in line with the
comics
we can now see that the belt has a much
more angular shape to it
which is way closer to the classic
design seen in the source material
though it was angled slightly and far
from home it wasn't to this degree
and this shows that there has been some
changes to it but whether they address
it or not in the movie
i really don't know it's it's nice just
to obsess over this type of stuff though
especially as i live in the uk where the
days of sun are doth a long distance
memory
and we doused eat an out but gruel
delicious gruel
i have to say though that this suit
looks absolutely gorgeous
and i really hope they don't cgi over
the top of it like they do in most of
the mcu movies
i wish they would stop with this habit
as it just ruins things and yeah
let the costume designers work be
displayed for once
now the last time we saw peter parker he
was getting exposed like some army
hammer dms that outlined cannibalism
but with peter it was much worse as he'd
murdered everyone's favorite fictional
superhero mysterio
this was clearly happening in the summer
as even london looks sunny
and that only happens about four days a
year however the leaked set photos
clearly show
snow and peter parker with slightly
longer hair than how we saw him last
time
i'm sure if the lad could grow a beer
that he'd definitely have one too
and this is probably the most dishevel
looking that we've ever seen the
character
it seems like he's been on the run from
home for a long time
and with the movie releasing in december
this year it could be possible that the
film itself is set at christmas
it's an awesome time setting for movies
and if you've played the miles morales
spider-man game
then you'll know new york looks
absolutely incredible during this time
of year
he's also wearing what looks to be an ac
dc t-shirt under his shirt
and this was of course a band that iron
man absolutely loved
showing how much he's taken up his
mantle now peter also has a bag over his
shoulder
which i'm guessing he might be using to
carry the suit or some of his fancy
fancy books
in homecoming his bag was stolen and
then he was seen holding them walking
home from school
so it could be possibly a similar
situation here where he has to dump it
as the black and red suit scene is
happening at the same location
just jared also caught holland wearing a
mask at one point
and a large overcoat like some central
park trench coat flasher
i think this was to cover up the costume
change and also i have no idea what this
blue mask is around his face
what's that there's a pandemic going on
here are you sure
i wish i wish someone had mentioned that
either way we can gather from the photos
that he's had a change of costume at
some point
but where exactly is the place that he's
heading to
well he's in fact going to the peter pan
at donut and pastry shop
okay now imagine kevin feige showing up
to set like you idiots
his name's peter parker not pan
or maybe that's just wishful thinking no
but this does carry a lot with it and i
have a fan theory about exactly what's
going on here
now this is a real-life location and it
can be found in new york
but they've clearly dressed it up for
winter so i don't think it's too much of
a reach to say that the name itself
carries a lot of significance
you also know from the character
announcements such as doctor octopus and
electro
that the multiverse will become a big
part of the film and that there will be
multiple versions of peter parker in the
movie
the deal with toby maguire has
reportedly been finalized
and andrew garfield was confirmed as
being part of the cast last month
now i actually have a theory that
they've purposely chosen the name peter
pan
because this may belong to another
version of peter parker who's entered
the main mcu timeline from across the
multiverse
and he's changed his name in order to
lie low anyway if one version of the web
head was hurtled across the multiverse
then they might try and avoid attention
in the mcu and nurse
would change their name to peter pan
open a bakery store
and just sell their hot cakes which are
probably selling like hot cakes hey
you're haven't that i kind of wish that
he was selling pizzas so i could do a
pizza time meme every video
but some men just want to watch the
world burn
peter pan is of course a character in
fiction that lived on another world
called neverland
and he traveled to earth in order to get
wendy and her brothers
thus this other version of peter might
be playing on this fact
and going under the name in order to pay
homage to his backstory
because hey that's scriptwriting 101 and
everyone has to leave a clue
i'm looking at you i get the harkness or
should i say agnes
now i think that tom holland's peter
might have learned about who this
character is from doctor strange
and that he will have gone to him in
order to try and help defeating all the
villains that are after him
potentially parker could arrive there in
his regular clothes
and then have to change into his costume
when the bad guys show up
this would allow for both peters to get
into their costumes and team up to take
down whoever is trying to collect the
bounty on parker's head
now strangely enough tom's brother harry
holland was
also seen on set harry is actually an
actor himself
but he hasn't been announced as being
cast in any roles
now this opens the door to a lot of
options and currently there are several
people speculating that he may be
playing harry osborne
osborne and peter though not brothers in
a literal sense
we're very close and thus it does make
sense to cast someone who looks similar
to the actor if they want to lean into
this aesthetic
however i think more likely than not
that this is simply a cameo role
rather than something major when actors
are embarking on big projects back to
back such as holland
who pretty much left the set of
uncharted to come and film this movie
it's nice for studios to find a way to
bring the fan back together
so they may have hired him to come on
set for a couple of days so that he
could spend
quality time with his bro shoots like
this pretty much kill your social life
and i should know as a start in weapons
of ass destruction 129
and it's probably the only time that
he's seen his sibling in quite a long
time
unless he's been having those quarantine
parties tom don't make me cancel you
now on top of this i'm glad that the
film is staying in new york
going from summer to winter in the city
likely means that he's remained there
whilst people hunted him in a sort of
john victory style
it was reported that charlie cox aka
daredevil has now finished filming his
role in the movie
and as he's the devil of hell's kitchen
and makes sense to remain here
with civil war infinity war end game and
far from home while being set outside
the city
i'm glad that we're finally getting the
wall crawler back where he belongs
as this is of course his home and it
makes sense as that word home
will likely feature in the title now for
the moment there are of course a lot of
theories
but i do think that these ones line up
quite a lot in terms of what we know
about the film
and of course the multiverse though now
trailer seems to be on the horizon just
yet
elizabeth olsen did state in her one
division interviews that there would be
some handoff from the series to
spider-man 3
so who knows we may even get a
post-credits scene at the end of it that
sets up the next events
anyway i'd of course love to hear your
thoughts and theories on it so make sure
you comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
straw in which we're giving away three
copies of the hobbit and lord of the
rings 4k box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications son and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the video
the winners are going to be chosen at
random on the 30th of january so best of
luck to everyone who takes part
now the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button
and as a thank you you get videos like
this early you just create an
instagram account i would love to see
you over there for cool behind the
scenes images and more
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
one division which will be linked on
screen right now
we went through the entire episode from
top to bottom and talking about all the
easter eggs and cool things that you
missed so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more
without the way thanks for sitting
through the video i've been paul you be
the best and i'll see you next time
take care peace